[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette émission spéciale consacrée
aux élections législatives 2022 et à
leurs résultats à nous sommes le lundi
20 juin au sommaire aujourd'hui
après le deuxième tour des législatives
dimanche les nouveaux députés ont pris
leurs marques ce matin à l'assemblée
nationale nous les avons suivis dans
leurs installations parmi les douze
représentant quatre nouvelles têtes
yvelinoise leur portrait à suivre à deux
circonscriptions ont basculé à gauche
dans les yvelines williams martinez et
benjamins lucas et candidat de la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale ont été élus respectivement
député de la 11e et de la 8e
circonscription
et puis
47,34 % des yvelinois ne se sont pas
rendus aux urnes ce week-end un taux en
baisse par rapport à 2010 est le point
sur l'abstention dans le département et
dans ce journal et puis nous parlerons
également à des beaux scores des députés
sortants et nous ferons le point sur
l'avenir des républicains après ces
élections législatives
[Musique]
hier dimanche 19 juin avait lieu donc le
deuxième tour des élections législatives
avant de débuter cette édition spéciale
voici l'état des lieux au niveau
national au terme de ce scrutin le parti
présidentiel n'obtient pas la majorité
quelle stratégie mettre en place pour
les partis c'est l'analyse de patrice
carmouze
cette élection législative est une
élection bien particulière puisque tout
le monde perd emmanuel macron père
puisqu'il n'aura pas de majorité à
l'assemblée nationale jean luc mélenchon
père puisqu'il ne sera pas premier
ministre comme il l'avait annoncé et
surtout parce que la gauche fait 29% des
voix soit un des scores les plus bas de
son histoire marine le pen perd certes
elle a plus de députés que de lui en
promettait les sondages mais elle ne
parvient toujours pas à transformer son
mouvement d'un mouvement protestataire
en parti de gouvernement
lr la droite républicaine père elle perd
la moitié de ses députés et les
négociations qui auront lieu
probablement dans les prochaines
semaines risquent plus encore de la
diviser assez défaite s'ajoute une crise
démocratique 25 millions des français ne
sont pas allés voter et 70% des jeunes
n'ont pas pris part à ce vote c'est deux
chiffres qui nous rappelle que
contrairement à ce qu'on croit souvent
la démocratie est un régime fragile on
pourrait ajouter que la france perd
aussi puisque face aux défis qui se
présentent à elle la guerre le risque de
crise financière et énergétique
le problème du réchauffement climatique
elle n'est pas unie elle est divisée
alors maintenant qu'est ce qui va se
passer on a une france 1 gouvernable
avec une majorité très relative trop
relative pour imposer ses réformes et
deux blocs extrême elle fit à gauche et
le rassemblement national à droite qui
vont se cantonner à une opposition
systématique alors la seule solution
pour le président de la république c'est
soit de trouver des majorités au cas par
cas ce qui ne va pas être facile soit de
passer un accord de gouvernement et avec
qui le passé elle vient avec une partie
des députés lr à quel prix c'est toute
la question peut-être en changeant de
premier ministre peut-être en renonçant
à certaines réformes peut-être en
droitisant sa politique la partie
s'annonce en tout cas très difficile
d'où cette hypothèse qu'on évoque déjà
du côté de l'elysée celle d'une
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
d'ici un an
et avec nous également pour analyser ces
élections législatives rappelle mata
duvignau bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes maître de conférences en droit
public à lui mais est ce qu est comme
pour la première édition spéciale pour
le premier tour des législatives vous
serez avec nous pendant une bonne partie
de cette émission alors qu'on vient
d'entendre cette analyse de patrice
carmouze quelle est votre analyse
peut-être personnel sur ce deuxième tour
peut-être plus haut niveau local comment
vous avez perçu ces élections ce
deuxième tour
alors effectivement patrice carmouze a
déjà pris quasiment tout dit la première
chose que que je remarquerai et le le
premier sentiment et je je souhaite
insister là dessus pour c'est vraiment
la forte abstention ça c'est
véritablement quelque chose sur lequel
on reviendra tout à l'heure mais
l'abstention est vraiment le mon avis la
grande gagnante de cette de cette
élection et finalement comme l'a dit
patrick carmouze c'est la france qui a
perdu c'est la démocratie qui est en
faible qui qui a perdu ensuite au niveau
institutionnel je répondrais d'abord sur
le plan institutionnel
c'est vrai que on observe avec avec le
résultat aujourd'hui que la france
finalement que l'assemblée nationale
qu'on va comporter des blocs de très
gros bloc des blocs compacts et au final
le scrutin majoritaire tel qu'il a été
appliquée hier donne lieu finalement à
des résultats assez sens assez similaire
à ce que pourrait donner une
un scrutin proportionnel donc ça c'est
un point assez intéressant et puis moi
ce que je retiens aussi et on en
reparlera après c'est que effectivement
le gouvernement va devoir rapport dont
la majorité présidentielle va devoir
trouver des
alliances des coalitions d'appoint
conjoncturel pour tel ou tel projet
cette majorité relative parce que le
parti du président a quand même gagné
ces élections malgré tout va quand même
va devoir trouver des alliances de
circonstance et ça si vous voulez pour
le citoyen c'est peut-être assez
paradoxal mais pour le juriste que je
suis c'est une période assez
passionnante qui sauve parce qu'on va
voir beaucoup de choses au niveau du
droit parlementaire qui vont qui vont
apparaître et justement là vous en
parliez un petit peu par rapport au
blocage que ça pourrait engendrer
comment peut faire face justement à
cette difficulté de la majorité
finalement relative du mouvement
ensemble
alors il ya plusieurs éléments la
première c'est que en effet le parti
présidentiel va devoir en tout cas si le
président de la république confie confie
le gouvernement a représentant du parti
du parti présidentiel va devoir trouver
sur des textes importants des appuis
alors je ne sais pas s'il y aura un
contrat gouvernement ça ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas à moi d'en parler mais en tout
état de cause pour avoir la majorité à
l'assemblée pour pouvoir voter les
textes le gouvernement devra se comment
dire composé devra négocier avec tel ou
tel parti alors on dit on parle des
républicains mais on peut parler aussi
peut-être dans certains cas du groupe ps
éventuellement donc ça c'est un élément
important et finalement ce que ce que
l'on retire que l'on retient finalement
c'est que par le parler ces résultats
permettent de revenir à une un droit
parlementaire à une un régime
parlementaire d origine c'est à dire pas
de fait majoritaire pas de
superpuissance du président de la
république mais un gouvernement qui va
devoir composer avec un parlement va
devoir négocier avec les partis et
finalement la culture du compromis la
culture de la négociation et du dialogue
mais de faire revivre le
démocratie et le droit parlementaire et
donc on revient finalement aux origines
peut-être de la vème république et est
ce que justement doit tirer donc des
enseignements de cette situation qui
finalement est arrivé une fois
alors les enseignements ça on en parlera
peut-être probablement après mais c'est
que le
monde est là
bon c'est une défaite quand même malgré
tout pour le parti présidentiel
mais en réalité les enseignements que
l'on en tire c'est que a ils sont
gentils sont nombreux mais sur le plan
institutionnel
le gouverneur chef du gouvernement le
futur chef du gouvernement va devoir
véritablement s'imposer par rapport à
son par rapport au parlant par rapport
aux groupes parlementaires et il va ya
voir comment dire un vrai jeu
parlementaire c'est la politique si vous
voulez reprendre le dessus le débat
démocratique va reprendre pas et moi ce
que je vois c'est que on n'aura plus
beaucoup de textes qui vont être adoptés
mais peut-être des deux textes parce
qu'il va y avoir ce compromis il va y
avoir
le gouvernement va devoir chercher je
répète encore ce que c'est ça qui est
important le gouvernement va devoir
chercher des compromis sur tel ou tel
texte va vous devoir trouver des
dénominateurs communs et au final ça
prendra plus de temps et on aura moins
de textes qui seront adoptées à revenir
un peu à la chaîne mais le travail
parlementaire sera peut-être un petit
peu plus le pas hier serein parce que
c'est pas le mot mais un petit peu plus
orienté vers un texte qui suscite et
c'est ça qui est important qu'ils
suscitent l'assentiment de des députés
le plus large possible et donc c'est un
point aussi important est peut-être
peut-être une meilleure qualité de la
loi on peut l'espérer mais a contrario
il y aura aussi un fort un phare une
forte obstruction de la part des partis
d'opposition donc voilà c'est un jeu qui
va on va c'est un laboratoire finalement
qui est en train de mettre en place et
les enseignements bar on les verra au
fur et à mesure on peut pas préjuger de
ce qui sera plus tard donc à suivre en
tout cas merci beaucoup elle rappelle
matin du vigneron vous restez avec nous
pendant l'émission mais pour l'instant
je vous propose après ce deuxième tour
donc des élections législatives ce
dimanche 19 juin je le rappelle de faire
un point sur les candidats qui ont été
élus donc députés dans le département et
c'est avec vous c'est lié à 400 go
bonsoir bonsoir alors est ce qu'on peut
faire un tour des résultats dans les
deux circonscriptions avec vous oui
alors les résultats ont vu naître
quelques surprises on s'attendait plus
ou moins un carton plat pour la majorité
présidentielle
à l'issue du premier tour donc dans les
yvelines et finalement score final 10
sur 12 de circonscription était remporté
par ensemble et on va commencer par ce
chiffre 71 faire que le 40% pour
béatrice piron réélu pour un second
mandat dans la troisième circonscription
des yvelines c'est elle qui obtient le
meilleur score pour ensemble elle était
face à louis ii brody de la nuque baisse
d'autres députés ensemble ont largement
été réélu comme jean noël barrot avec 64
père qui le 27 % des voix on peut citer
aussi quatre femmes qui ont été
également un très confortablement réélue
en totalisant à chaque fois plus de 60%
des voix il ya elle est productive et
natalia pouzy réf aurore bergé et marie
le bec alors avec un peu moins de 60%
des voix bruno myle yen est également
réélu dans la 9e circonscription des
yvelines il était opposé aux seuls
candidats fn au second tour laurent
maurin et donc si on reste un peu dans
la majorité présidentielle il ya quand
même trois nouvelles têtes plus ou moins
connu un qui rentre ou font leur retour
en tout cas à l'assemblée nationale oui
et on va commencer par le député le plus
jeune des douze circonscriptions un nom
juste il alors il me semble que c'est
monsieur rodwell première
circonscription ces jardins réviser ses
traits c'est charles rondeau elle a 25
ans il devient le nouveau député de la
première circonscription
autre petit nouveau
karl olive maire de poissy il rentre à
l'assemblée en devenant un député de la
12e circonscription est une
particularité nadia et qui retrouve son
siège au sein de l'hémicycle autrefois
aux députés dans la 11e elle revient
dans la septième en battant michel
christophoul avec 55,64 % des voix mais
ont fini aux familles oui on fait ça ce
taux peut être avec elle et résultats
des candidats finalement les deux
candidats de la nouvelle coalition d'ong
du ps oui donc la gauche a gagné deux
députés dans les yvelines williams
martinez dans la 11e circonscription
tout juste élu avec environ une centaine
de voix d'avancé et dans la 8e
circonscription un territoire de mantes
la jolie c'est benjamin mika merci
beaucoup célia gars de son goût pour ces
informations alors raphaël mata duvignau
on vient de voir ses résultats dans les
yvelines est-ce qu'ils sont
représentatifs aussi finalement du
territoire du national en fait
alors d'une certaine manière oui puisse
pas alors je pense que la sociologie
aussi des yvelines département des
yvelines est assez particulière est
assez caractéristique qui ce qui permet
justement d'avoir une très forte
majorité pour le parti présidentiel
mais ce qui est intéressant de voir
c'est que au niveau nations qu'on part
les yvelines par rapport au rapport aux
résultats nationaux c'est que d'une
certaine manière là quand il ya la
majorité présidentielle a gagné des voix
par rapport au premier tour on voit que
là on voit que la dire le pourcentage
finalement si on fait simplement un
pourcentage des voix la majorité
présidentielle a gagné ac sont
accentuées par dans son avance alors que
la gauche a un petit peu marqué le pas
ça c'est un premier point un deuxième
point c'est que à l'issue du second du
1er tour pardon souvent les résultats
entre les deux premiers candidats était
un peu serré et on voit finalement que
malgré tous les candidats de la majorité
présidentielle ont quand même ont réussi
à conserver leur avance et à l'emporter
et donc au final où est ce que j'aurai
dire c'est que malgré la percée malgré
la percée de la gauche alors je ne vais
pas vous voyez d'autres termes pour
l'instant mais la percée de la gauche
finalement
les les français ont malgré tout décidé
alors peut-être bon gré mal gré mais
décidé de laisser une majorité au
président de la république ou majorité
que relative mais en tout état de cause
on s'aperçoit quand même que le que la
majorité présentielle conserve un socle
assez important et puis en réalité il
faut bien voir que quand on fait le
compte refait les calculs la majorité
présidentielle a quand même plus de 100
députés d' avance par rapport à la
gauche alors on prédisait un un score
beaucoup plus serré et donc au final le
c'est pas nous c'est pas nous c'est pas
une victoire mais en tout cas la
majorité présentielle à limiter les
dégâts si l'on pardonne et d'expression
et du coup on y reviendra aussi en fin
de journal un seul abstention mais je
voudrais un mot de votre part à là
dessus que ce que vous disiez voilà
forcément c'est toujours ce qui fâche
l'abstention aux élections est pourtant
finalement les des bons élèves dans les
yvelines et ont fait mieux qu'en 2017
c'est vrai mais on veut mais les
yvelines est un est un territoire qui
alors c'est par là que ça veut dire mais
c'est un territoire qui va te dire que
les les citoyens qui vivent dans les
yvelines ont une haute conscience de la
démocratie et finalement se sont
investis de leurs devoirs des citoyens
et vont voter même si même si ils ne se
retrouvent pas dans les candidats qui
leur sont proposés en tout cas ils vont
exercer leur devoir de citoyen et ça
vous regarde manière c'est à saluer et
parce que l'abstention par après mais la
tension pour l'instant ne mène à rien ne
mène à rien il n'y a pas de
reconnaissance du vote blanc ou du vote
donc voilà je pense que là il ya une
conscience une conscience citoyenne qui
fait que chez les divines loi par
tradition on va voter plus qu'ailleurs
on peut on peut développer l'abstention
maintenant à vous disiez vous disais
justement vous êtes en train d'analyser
l'abstention n'y a pas de reconnaissance
pour l'instant c'est ça le problème
aujourd'hui en fait l'absence en fait il
ya plusieurs typologies d'abstention
quand on fait de la sociologie politique
on voit qu'il ya plusieurs types
d'abstention il ya d'une part
l'abstention de tradition il ya des
personnes qui ne vont jamais voté parce
qu'ils ne s'intéressent pas à la
politique et parce qu'il considère que
le personnel politique ne répond pas aux
eaux au besoin donc ça voilà sur une
abstention des abstentionnistes on va
dire récurrents malgré qu'on fasse ils
n'iront pas voter ensuite il ya des
abstentionnistes on va dire de
circonstance c'est à dire que ils
considèrent qu'ils ne sont pas
représentés et par conséquent c'est à
dire que personne ne m'a grâce à leurs
yeux et par conséquent ils ne vont pas
se dépasser parce que ils ne savent pas
pour qui voter et ils n'ont pas envie de
voter pour quelqu'un avec qui ne
partagent pas leur des opinions prix il
ya aussi les abstentionnistes stratégie
c'est à dire que certains vont dire je
ne vais pas voter
faire soit pour contrer tel ou tel parti
je peux pour favoriser telle ou telle
partie j'en sais rien mais en tout état
de cause on les études de sociologie
politique montre qu'il y a dans certains
cas une stratégie pour ne pas aller
voter ce qui a conduit un phénomène
intéressant c'est que je ne vais pas
voter donc la personne qui sera élu sera
mal élu donc elle sera plus légitime et
donc j'aurai la possibilité a posteriori
de critiques et de contester et de dire
que je ne suis pas représenté
donc il ya plusieurs facteurs à prendre
en considération je ne sais pas lesquels
sont ces facteurs là dans tout état de
cause voilà sept abstentions la cei a
plusieurs visages qu'il faut qu'il faut
un qu'il faut pouvoir analyser et puis
il y à aussi de l'abstention de ce
qu'ils sont je vais employer un terme
qui n'est pas très scientifique mais qui
sont on va dire des goûters fâché pour
pas dire autre chose par rapport au
politique désabusé désabusé plus
politique cette crise de confiance cette
crise de lien civique elle est quand
même assez assez prégnante en france
depuis un certain nombre d'années et
aujourd'hui c'est pour voir une vraie
crise politique qui est
rien
malheureusement une crise politique qui
se retrouvent à chacune des élections
merci beaucoup je vous le disais je vous
le disais en titrant tout à l'heure pour
prendre leurs marques au sein de leur
nouveau lieu de travail elle les
nouveaux députés donc élu dimanche ont
pris leurs marques justement à
l'assemblée nationale à karl olive et
charles rodwell dont on parlait tout à
l'heure était présent à dès ce matin et
nous avons pu les suivre le reportage de
patrick jacques de dixmude et mathilde
de francs coup
dès le lendemain des législatives
l'assemblée nationale organise une
procédure d'accueil pour permettre aux
élus de s'approprier leur nouvel espace
de travail arrivé très tôt ce matin à 6h
karl olive le nouveau député de la 12e
circonscription des yvelines est l'un
des premiers à se présenter au palais
bourbon d'abord on a dormi peu on s'est
retrouvé très tôt ce matin à 6 heures
ici on a fait un peu le parcours
initiatique c'est le même parcours que
le gamin qui va entrer pour la première
fois en section maternelle et puis il ya
évidemment l'émotion d'un enfant de la
république qui se retrouve au coeur de
la démocratie
aperçu également charles rodwell le
nouveau député de la première
circonscription en compagnie d'aurore
berger pour l'aider à prendre ses
marques chacun repart avec sa pochette
d'accueil comprenant son écharpe
tricolore
son nom signe sa cocarde et ses codes
informatiques pour se connecter à son
nouveau bureau parmi les huit
commissions permanentes à l'assemblée
nationale car le livre a ses préférences
moi j'aimerais intégrer la commission la
commission des lois gg un certain nombre
de sujets sur lequel je suis très
sensible le non-cumul député vert pour
moi c'est vraiment une connerie
aujourd'hui on a besoin d'avoir des
remontées de terrain la création du
conseiller territorial également et puis
peut-être profiter de cet instant
historique en france pour bouleverser
aussi nos habitudes peut être changer
l'ordre de séquence électorale a apporté
un vote électronique faire de la
proportionnelle et c'est il ya plein de
petites choses il faut en profiter la
les nouveaux députés ont jusqu'à
vendredi 24 juin pour se présenter à
l'assemblée nationale le mardi 28 juin
signera bel et bien la date de la
rentrée les 577 députés sont appelés à
siéger en séance publique pour
l'élection de celui ou de celle qui
présidera l'hémicycle des députés donc
vous venez de le voir qui commence à
s'installer et sur les 12 députés ville
élu ce dimanche quatre le sont pour la
première fois et gmt mayence entité ban
journalistes pour télé 78 vous nous avez
justement rejoint en plateau pour nous
donner plus de précisions vous allez
nous présenter ces nouveaux visages donc
yvelinois qui occuperont donc l
assemblée nationale mais en effet vous
l'avez dit on l'a vu se soit installée
dans les locaux de l'assemblée certains
sont arrivés tôt ce matin pour prendre
les meilleurs bureaux paraît-il charles
bedouelle benjamins lucas williams
martinez car le livre le premier était
sous la bannière ensemble et sera l'un
des plus jeunes va c'est à siéger au
palais bourbon charles bedouelle 25 ans
et originaire de sa circonscription la
première où il a été élu à 163 points
31% devant le candidat de la nuit passe
sébastien gamache il a deux mentors
bruno le maire qui l'a accompagné au
ministère de l'économie et françois de
mazères actuel maire de versailles dont
il est adjoint à la jeunesse depuis 2020
versailles est depuis l'âge de 7 ans il
ne compte pas oublié ses origines dans
la prise de ses nouvelles fonctions
donc charles de gaulle pour la première
circonscription vous en avez parlé on va
peut-être passer au suivant avec deux
candidats de l'année passée avec d'abord
benjamin lucas élus sur la 8e
circonscription c'est un amiénois de
naissance il fait même ses études de
droit à l'université de picardie jules
verne pourtant ce n'est pas un hasard
s'il s'est présenté dans les yvelines en
effet il est cofondateur du mouvement
générations s avec quelqu'un que le
territoire connaît bien benoît hamon il
y à il y occupe d'abord un poste de
sécrétaire général plus de porte parole
à 31 ans il devient aujourd'hui le
cinquième député d'un parti de gauche
sur la circo de mantes-la-jolie mantes
la ville ou encore lee mais ensuite le
candidat élu pour un peu plus de cent
voix d' avance dans la 11e
circonscription williams martinez ancien
président de l'union nationale des
étudiants de france unef de 2013 à 2016
il est aussi licencié de biologie à
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines cette candidature yvelinoise
aux législatives c'était donc un retour
dans le département pour lui un retour
aux sources qui l'y a occupé plusieurs
rôles au sein du parti de la france
insoumise il a été co responsable du
pôle organisation puis responsable de
l'écriture et de la coordination du plan
zéro sdf pour la récente campagne
présidentielle de jean luc mélenchon et
enfin le dernier à nouveau candidat
nouveau député bien connu des yvelinois
dans la circonscrit même d'au-delà du
département en effet c'est bien entendu
karl olive l'actuel maire de poissy a
été élue devant le candidat de la nuque
baisse edwin legris ancien journaliste
sportif producteur de télévision
entrepreneurs et j'en passe ce mandat
c'est une activité de plus qui s'ajoute
aux cv du pisciacais anciens du parti
des républicains aussi qu'il quitte en
2019 il est désormais sous la bannière
de la majorité présidentielle ensemble
avec ce mandat il devra quitter son mot
son poste de maire de poissy au profit
de sa première adjointe sandrine dos
santos par contre il peut conserver ses
deux sièges au conseil départemental et
à l'agglomération grand paris seine et
oise enfin hypothèse qu'il ne faut pas
exclure non plus justin il pourrait
peut-être se voir confier un ministère
avec le probable futur remaniement qui
devrait avoir lieu merci beaucoup
bixente manière santesteban d'avoir été
avec nos journalistes pourquoi tv 78
peut-être une dernière petite question
pour vous rappelle mathias vigneau
puisque on doit vous laisser après vous
avez d'autres obligations ce sont donc
des nouveaux des nouveaux visages qui
ont convaincu a priori
convaincu je ne sais pas en tout cas ils
s'étaient plus quel qu'il soit porteur
d'un projet porteur d' aspiration
je sais pas s'ils sont convaincus que je
peux pas vous là vous me posez une colle
je ne peux pas vous répondre en tout
état de cause ce qui est sûr c'est que
les électeurs ont choisi de les envoyer
à l'assemblée nationale non ça veut dire
que ils ont malgré tout réussi à
faire adhérer à leur projet et à l'heure
et à leur personnalité c'est là voilà je
ne peux pas vous dire s'ils ont vraiment
convaincu de ce voile a lâché désolé non
notre souci c'est entendu en tout cas
merci beaucoup raphaël mata de vigneault
d'avoir été avec nous pendant ce début
d'émission je le rappelle un vous vous
pardon je peux pas
je le rappelle quand même vous êtes
maître de conférences en droit public et
vous restez encore un petit moment avec
avec nous alors du coup on va passer à
une autre thématique avec vous mais
calais lemay d'euros journaliste
également pour tv 78 s'il ya des
nouveaux donc on vient de le voir dans
les yvelines de nombreux députés ont
réussi finalement à conserver leurs
sièges à l'assemblée nationale et ont
fait l'état des lieux avec vous ils sont
huit députés de 2017 à être réélu pour
un nouveau mandat dans le détail jean
noël barrot est réélu assez facilement
avec plus de 60% des suffrages il
s'impose au deuxième tour face à maïté
qu'arrive b doit ni dans la 5e
circonscription la députée sortante et
nouvelle ministre des outre-mer à yale
brunch iv est arrivé largement en tête
des suffrages face à la candidate du ps
sophie ah tu es venu j'ai un vrai motif
de satisfaction dans la mesure où
j'améliore grandement mon score de 2017
que ce soit en pourcentage ou en nombre
de voix ce qui est satisfaisant parce
que c'est finalement la preuve que le
travail que j'ai effectué un travail de
terrain travail de rassemblement à payer
est juste à côté donc dans la sixième
circonscription natalia pouzy l'efs deux
ans on qui va repartir pour un nouveau
mandat comme en 2010 est elle assez
facilement remporté sa circonscription
avec 64 52 % des suffrages face à la
candidate nubes melinda sauge et on
écoute natalia pouzy réf je crois que
c'est un c'est un bon score même un très
bon score je pense aussi que mon
implantation à payer je me suis
intéressé à toutes les huiles de cette
circonscription dans la 10e
circonscription aurore bergé est arrivée
une nouvelle fois première la femme
politique de 35 ans et réélu avec plus
de 60% des suffrages un chiffre
quasiment identique à celui de 2010 est
où elle avait récolté à cette époque là
74% des suffrages à côté dans la 9e
circonscription le député sortant bruno
millièmes s'impose face à laurent maurin
du rassemblement national comme en 2010
est tirée cote un peu plus de 50% des
voix il se projette déjà sur son nouveau
mandat de l'otan n'est plus venu à
l'idéal politique franchement dans cette
circonscription il faut qu'on se serre
tous les coudes mais je suis entièrement
la disney leur disposition pour
travailler même au niveau local à faire
en sorte que les gens on améliore leur
quotidien et si les maires ont des
difficultés à faire passer c'est une
telle chose elles peuvent compter sur
moi et on passe maintenant à la 4e
circonscription avec là encore une
réélection dans la 4e circonscription la
jeune députée de 31 ans marie le bec va
aussi repartir pour un nouveau mandat
avec la majorité présidentielle après sa
victoire face à céline bourdon tout
comme béatrice piron qui a largement
remporté la 3e circonscription face à
luis brody de nu baisse à la meilleure
c'est score par rapport à 2010 est où
elle avait enfin l'avait emporté face à
philippe brillault avec 58 points 93 %
des suffrages elle a été interrogée par
le confrère de radio sensations
localement sur ma circonscription
j'avais quand même de très grosses
chances de gagner puisque les chiffres
me mettais largement en tête
d'informations reçues enfin élu député
en 2017 sur la 11e circonscription avant
de démissionner en 2020 pour prendre le
poste de ministre délégué chargé de la
ville nadia il sera de nouveau député
mais cette fois ci dans la septième à la
battue michel christophoul ce dimanche
19 juin merci beaucoup mais qu'elle elle
me dire aux journalistes pour tv 78 en
parlant de nadia et vous êtes avec nous
ou avec nous pardon soir
vous êtes donc député de la 7e
circonscription des yvelines alors vous
êtes donc avec nous pour l'instant on
l'a entendu des bons résultats un
michael et demi d'euros vient de de nous
le dire pour ce parti présidentiel est
ce qu'on peut parler d'une victoire pour
ensemble bien sûr bien sûr qu'il s'agit
d'une victoire nous sommes
la première force politique de
l'assemblée nationale nous avons un
groupe de députés fort de 247
parlementaire et donc oui nous avons
gagné sept cette élection maintenant
effectivement le résultat n'est pas à la
hauteur de nos espérances parce que nous
pensions pouvoir acquérir la majorité
absolue ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui donc ça nous amène
évidemment à avoir une grosse réflexion
autour de cela mais mais oui il s'agit
bien d'une victoire et et a fortiori
dans les yvelines où nous conservons nos
dix sièges sur 10 ce qui est pour nous
une belle performance belle performance
donc on l'a vu dix circonscriptions
c'était 11 en 2010 est qu'est-ce qui a
changé qu'est ce qui a fait justement
que qu'on n'a pas cette dernière
circonscription finalement selon vous
eh bien nous avions des candidats
les deux les deux sièges la 11e et la
huitième n'étant pas ceux de la majorité
à la fin d'année 2022 pardon pardon au
moment dé des suffrages
exprimés et bien là on n'a pas réussi à
conquérir ses deux sièges il y avait
évidemment des spécificités
territoriales des villes avec des
quartiers populaires où le vote s'est
davantage exprimé en faveur de l'extrême
gauche pendant la présidentielle et donc
qui confirme finalement
la tendance qui a été celle de
l'élection présidentielle donc ce n'est
pas une très grosse surprise nous
savions que sur ces deux
circonscriptions nous allions en
conquête et bien malheureusement nous
avions deux très belles candidates qui
ont fait une campagne de terrain qui n'a
absolument rien à regretter
surtout ce qu'elles ont fait accompli ce
dernier mois mais bon cela n'a pas suffi
pour pour conquérir les deux sièges qui
nous manquait donc oui je le rappelle un
vous connaissez bien la 11e
circonscription puisque vous avez été
élu en 2007 dans cette circonscription
justement alors en tant que député de la
7e cette fois ci comment vous allez
réagir justement par rapport à la
situation on en parle est un de majorité
relative de votre votre mouvement
finalement à l'assemblée nationale eh
bien nous allons devoir bâtir une
majorité de projet c'est à dire vraiment
d'aller projet par projet convaincre les
députés qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui qui
ne font pas partie de la majorité
d'aller construire avec eux aussi
il me semble qu'on vous a perdu
on vous a retrouvé en vous à retrouver
ce bon
des projets d ensemble des propositions
aussi pour faire avancer nos mesures et
donc voilà on va on va continuer à
travailler au dedans le dépassement des
clivages comme nous l'avons toujours été
et puis faire le lien avec le terrain
nous nous apercevons que finalement la
doctrine qui est parfois on peut
déployer à l'échelle nationale par les
responsables nationaux n'est pas
forcément celle qui est déployée par les
élus locaux qui sont davantage dans la
construction
avec leur député leurs représentants à
l'échelle nationale et donc c'est dans
cet état d'esprit que je vais évidemment
travailler dans cette septième
circonscription au delà des clivages
avec une méthode vraiment peut être
renouvelée et est davantage ancré sur le
terrain je pense que ça c'est important
c'est attendu de nos concitoyens et
l'appel qu'il a été lancé par nos
concitoyens a été largement entendu on
appelle entendu donc merci beaucoup on a
des rides avoir été avec nous je le
rappelle vous êtes donc la député de la
7e circonscription des yvelines merci
beaucoup
et williams martinez et benjamins lucas
font partie aussi des nouveaux députés
ils ont été élus de la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale ils ont
emporté donc respectivement le scrutin
dans la 11e et la 8e circonscription
c'était donc on l'a dit ce dimanche 19
juin alors comment la gauche at-elle
gagné ces deux territoires les détails
dans ce reportage dé nicolas d'andré la
gauche avait percé au premier tour des
élections législatives la gauche
confirme son retour dans les yvelines la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
social aura deux députés yvelinois
l'assemblée nationale suite aux
élections législatives d'abord dans la
8e circonscription benjamins lucas
s'impose largement j'ai fait campagne
depuis des semaines auprès des habitants
et des habitants pour convaincre pour
mobiliser parce que j'ai entendu des
souffrances parce que j'ai entendu aussi
des envies des attentes des aspirations
qui correspondait je crois à ce que je
portais à ce que nous portions dans
cette campagne sur le pouvoir d'achat
sur la justice sociale notamment sur le
respect et la dignité pour chacune et
pour chacun
donc ça ne me surprend pas c'est
l'ampleur du résultat qui me surprend en
revanche parce qu'il est très large et
plus large que ce que je croyais pas ce
qu'a fait la différence c'est qu'on a
fait campagne d'arrache-pied qu'on est
allé voir des milliers de gens qu'on a
frappé à des milliers de portes que
qu'on a échangé qu'on a écouté ça a été
une campagne de dialogue une campagne
d'idées en tête lors du premier tour le
candidat de la nouvelle récolte 5000
voix supplémentaires au second tour sur
l'ensemble de la circonscription à
mantes la jolie le dépasse les 60% avec
une abstention plus faible qu'au premier
tour résultat pour moi même quinze mille
[Applaudissements]
même phénomène dans la 11e
circonscription williams martinez
devient le député de ce territoire il
devance la candidate de la majorité
présidentielle
aurélie pia senza 217 voix seulement
notre réservoir de voix c'était les
abstentionnistes voilà il n'y avait rien
d'automatique et de et de mécanique pour
pouvoir faire plus de 50% des voix il a
fallu retourner sur le terrain et à
réussir à convaincre à la fois nos
propositions mais ça c'était pas le plus
difficile le smic à 1500 euros la
retraite à 60 ans le blocage des prix
c'est des mesures qui sont majoritaires
ultra majoritaire dans le pays ce qui a
été le plus difficile c'est de
convaincre qu'il était possible de
gagner bien entendu est arrivé en tête à
trappes qui est la première ville de la
circonscription donc c'est ce qui a fait
l'écart entre
a priori sur sur les résultats attrape
le candidat de la nouvelle récolte 78%
des suffrages avec une participation
plus importante par rapport au premier
tour sur l'ensemble de la 11e
circonscription où il ya martin et gagne
un peu moins de 5000 voix par rapport au
premier scrutin
rappelle matt a dit vigneault peut être
brièvement comment on explique
finalement ce basculement et puis est-ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer un peu si
ça acte le retour de la gauche dont
département qui plutôt
traditionnellement de droite finalement
à bord je ne vous ai je vous ai mal
entendu
je voulais voir avec vous brièvement si
on peut expliquer un peu ce basculement
et puis si ce basculement justement acte
le retour de la gauche dans les yvelines
alors le basculement à nadia elle l'a
bien expliqué a notamment sur le fait
que les les circonscriptions qui ont été
gagnées par la gauche
n'était pas occupé si vous voulez
auparavant par des représentants de la
majorité en tous cas du parti du parti
présidentiel
ça s'explique également par la
sociologie un tout simplement la
sociologie électorale fait que
manifestement les personnes qui se sont
déplacés pour aller voter avait plus
d'appétence pour un candidat qui votent
ingrat candidat qui représente les
valeurs les valeurs de la gauche je ne
sais pas si c'est un retour de la gauche
dans les yvelines mais en tout état de
cause c'est un rééquilibrage des
situations et d'une certaine manière ça
permet également là aussi d'éviter une
sorte d'hégémonie et
le fait que la gauche r ce repère ce au
sein de l'enceinte des yvelines est
quand même un élément significatif et
qui montre peut-être peut-être que
il y a un début je ne sais pas un début
de modifications delà de la composition
du corps électoral qui fait que les
idées de gauche dans certains endroits
deviennent peut-être un petit peu plus
majoritaires que qu'ailleurs
c'est en tout cas dans le cas dans les
yvelines donc voilà c'est peut-être ça
le sait peut-être cet enseignement mais
à vérifier dans cinq ans à vérifier plus
tard lors des élections intermédiaires
départementales municipales régionales
pour voir si c'est vraiment un retour de
la gauche aussi si c'est seulement
hausse il ne faut pas l'oublier il faut
pas l'occulter un rejet un rejet aussi
des des candidats qui représente le
parti présidentiel parce que ça aussi
c'est un élément important
je pense qu'il ya aussi dans les
yvelines comme en france aussi un rejet
un rejet du parti présidentiel plus
peut-être qu'une véritable adhésion
merci rappelle mme haddad duvignau est
justement pour revenir sur ses résultats
dans le département de la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale nous
recevrons avec tous en plateau le
porte-parole donc départemental de la
france insoumise sébastien d'un mage
bonsoir bonsoir alors justement je vais
vous demander un petit peu la même
question de vous étiez candidat dans la
première circonscription des yvelines je
propose de faire un retour peut-être sur
les résultats dans le département on a
dit de députés élus pour pour la nuit
baisse dans la 8e et la 11e
circonscription est ce que c'est un
bilan satisfaisant et justement vous
comment vous voyez ce basculement je
pense effectivement que c'est
satisfaisant passe de 0 à 2 et lui est
tout à leur madame nadia ai parlé de
l'extrême gauche qui faisait une percée
sur département en vérité on renoue avec
des scores à deux chiffres de la gauche
avant son effondrement dans les années
2012 du fait du mandat de monsieur
hollande et donc on voit bien que la
sociologie électorale les gens qui ont
une appétence pour la gauche c'est
surtout ceux qui ont besoin de la gauche
et qui subissent le plus la politique d'
emmanuel macron les quartiers populaires
les villes populaires en moyenne et bien
notre notre mouvement arrive en tête
dans l'ensemble de ces zones là parce
que le voilà les gens et ils ont besoin
de politiques sociales ils ont besoin de
sortir la tête de l'eau et c'est nos
politiques qui répondent alors on va
faire le point aussi sur les autres
résultats puisqu'on peut souligner aussi
les résultats de michel christophoul
dans la septième avec 44% vous vous
d'ailleurs dans la première aussi avec
36% il ya aussi edwin le gris dont la
12e avec 40% et d'ailleurs on avait sa
réaction c'est au micro de mika la nuit
de regarder nous sommes heureux du
travail accompli on est et
même pas donnée au second tour on est
arrivé au second tour on a emmené notre
adversaire au second tour ce qui était
une première pour lui et on a fait des
bons résultats à poissy et surtout un
plaisir ou on perd simplement 51 49 ce
qui est un très bon résultat et qui est
le résultat d'un travail de
porte-à-porte de proximité qu'on a
menées sur toute la circonscription
donc ce qui veut dire que hormis louise
brody dans la troisième vous dépasser
tous quand même les 30% même dans les
zones pourtant qui sont ancrés à droite
traditionnellement est ce qu'on peut
parler justement je posais la même
question à monsieur matte a dit
vigneault est ce qu'on peut parler du
retour de la gauche dans les yvelines
selon vous alors oui mais une nouvelle
force une nouvelle force de gauche la
nouvelle union populaire c'est pas la
même gauche que cave en 2012 comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure et je
pense que là la force qu'on a sur ce
département et même nationalement c'est
extrêmement clair identifiable au niveau
de nos idées le programme de la nuit
baisse c'est le smic à 1500 la retraite
à 60 ans le blocage des prix et ça c'est
un message simple facile à comprendre
c'est pas de la politique de mesurettes
ou de la bureaucratie et c'est quelque
chose qui fonctionne maintenant nous on
regrette quand même une chose je pense
que
les adversaires aussi disent le
regretter mais en vérité c'est nous qui
subissons le plus l'abstention parce que
si vous regardez les quartiers
populaires les villes populaires c'est
en moyenne cinq à dix points de
participation en moins par rapport aux
quartiers entre guillemets favoriser et
donc nous on subit de plein fouet sa y
compris sur cette circonscription moi je
pense que je serai au coude à coude voir
devant si les habitants des quartiers
populaires et aller davantage voté
pendant pendant ces élections donc
maintenant ça nous donne nous une
feuille de route pour les cinq
prochaines années on sait qui on doit
les mobiliser on sait à qui doit on doit
parler on sait qui on doit convaincre
que le bureau de vote c'est un lieu où
on fait des bouchers des colères et des
revendications pour gagner à la fin et
justement là en parler un peu de votre
votre circonscription donc la première
donc à la englobe montigny le bretonneux
guyancourt et versailles
elle est construite aujourd'hui est ce
qu'elle est gagna finalement par un
candidat de la gauche selon vous où
toutes les circonscriptions de france
sont gagnables on vend souvent le mythe
de la circonscription bourgeoise droit
de droite avi en vérité que vous soyez à
versailles ou à guyancourt si vous êtes
un bourgeois vous avez toujours besoin
de serveurs dans les cafés de gens qui
vont aller nettoyer les rues de gens qui
vont travailler faire tourner les
entreprises en vrai notre camp social
les gens qui ont besoin de la gauche et
qui ont besoin de nos mesure où qu'ils
soient en france même dans le césar 16e
arrondissement est majoritaire est la
preuve en est montigny le bretonneux
ville historiquement à gauche à droite
et bien nous faisons un score quasiment
au coude à coude avec le candidat
de la reine donc voilà la preuve la
preuve en est par ce résultat y compris
à versailles en fait presque un tiers
des voix donc je pense que cette
circonscription comme toutes les autres
elle est gagnable et enfin nos idées
sont fortes nos idées sont fortes la
solidarité le partage et je pense que
oui non un corpus idéologique il faut
convaincre le plus grand nombre donc là
on l'a dit sur le territoire yvelinois
en tout cas deux députés élus ps et
qu'elles vont peut-être justement les
axes principaux de travail alors
monsieur martin est il est ancien
syndicaliste étudiant donc forcément il
va beaucoup travailler sur la question
de l'éducation et le de l'éducation de
proximité vous l'avez vu avec paris
saclay notamment se pose la question de
que vous devez du futur de nos
universités de proximité mais aussi
celle du logement dans les yvelines
c'est un sujet sur lequel il a beaucoup
travaillé et dans les yvelines ont subi
de plein fouet la crise du logement
social le manque de logements et surtout
l'envolée des prix on est quasiment ici
à saint quentin en yvelines sur les
mêmes prix que qu'à paris et donc oui ça
c'est un combat combat qu'on va porter
sur le département et ça va beaucoup
nous aider je parle en tant que
conseiller municipal de gauche d'avoir
dans le coin des députés qui sont sur
nos idées qui vont pousser nos combats
sur cette question là une dernière
petite question peut-être avant de vous
laisser votre mouvement politique à a
annoncé vouloir déposer une motion de
censure quel est l'objectif et est ce
qu'il pourrait y avoir des répercussions
sur le département alors il s'agit
simplement de dire que
la majorité qui qui qui en train de se
construire avec le gouvernement et il
faut croire la droite parce que c'est à
peu près tout ce qui leur reste pour
gouverner eh bien nous nous ne sommes
pas d'accord avec et d'ailleurs c'est
pas c'est pas un secret c'est normal ça
notre rôle d'opposition de s'opposer à
l'assemblée nationale maintenant à eux
en face parce que ça sera pas la fin des
juges du monde de déposer une motion de
censure ils vont devoir s'allier trouver
des compromis mais du coup s'ils veulent
un compromis de plus large possible
peut-être de remettre en cause leur
leurs programmes leurs réformes qui sont
imposés depuis le début par une seule
personne emmanuel macron qui décide de
tout dans ce pays enfin peut-être qu'on
va mettre fin à ça avec une assemblée
nationale qui sera souveraine enfin les
qui jouera son rôle est peut-être
brièvement une dernière petite question
quand même comment va s'organiser dans
le département l'opposition jusqu'aux
prochaines échéances donc élection eh
bien on a appris à travailler ensemble
et on va continuer à le faire partout
sur tout le département maintenant je
j'espère voilà que la nuit baisse va
perdurer parce que c'est une stratégie
qui est gagnante la preuve on est passé
de zéro à deux députés et donc c'est
quelque chose qu'il faudra continuer
très bien c'est entendu merci beaucoup
c'est la tiens ramage d'avoir été avec
nous je le rappelle un vous êtes le
porte parole départemental de la
française devant un des porte-paroles
pardon en ce qui concerne en tout cas le
rassemblement national à présent il n'y
aura aucun député yvelinois à
l'assemblée laurent morin était le seul
candidat fn au second tour il a été
battu par bruno myle yens dans la 9e
circonscription des yvelines laurent
morin a totalisé quand même 42,15 % des
voix il a gagné à des villes
périurbaines comme bonnières-sur-seine
encore mais les cours on écoute
justement laurent morin sur sa défaite
au micro de ces diaga tsongo c'est une
satisfaction d'obtenir 40 2%
approximativement sur cette
circonscription très difficile d'un
point de vue
électorale ces trois points de plus que
le score de marine le pen au second tour
de l'élection présidentielle sur cette
circonscription là donc c'est une grande
satisfaction bien sûr il ya une pointe
de déception parce que quand on débute
une compétition quelle qu'elle soit
c'est pour la gagner donc on n'est
jamais totalement satisfait bien sûr
d'une défaite mais dans cet océan de
victoire ce soir au niveau national pour
le rassemblement national les destins
personnels finalement passe
en seconde position
et on reste à droite de l'échiquier
politique le parti des républicains a
décroché 61 sièges à l'assemblée
nationale deux fois moins par rapport à
2017 et pourtant les députés aient l'air
pourrait jouer un rôle clé pour rendre
possible une majorité à du mouvement
ensemble au sein de l'hémicycle et pour
en parler en plateau nicolas d'andry
bonsoir déchets rustine journalistes
pour tv 78 alors finalement quelle
attitude vont devoir adopter les
républicains bien pour le moment la
position du parti elle est claire nous
resterons l'opposition voilà comment
christian christian jacob oui le
président des républicains a présenté la
position du parti mais au sein du
mouvement certains prônent un pacte de
gouvernement c'est le cas notamment de
jean françois copé du côté des
représentants et binoy le président de
la fédération yvelinoise des
républicains est aussi président du
conseil départemental des yvelines
pierre bédier par le jeu site d'une
ligne d'opposition parlementaire
constructive et je vous propose
d'écouter la sénatrice des yvelines
sophie primas par rapport à cette
position qu'il faut adopter par rapport
à un ensemble ou en tout cas je suis
totalement opposé je pense que ça
participe de l'espèce de confusion
générale encore plus de l'éloignement
moi je pense que les républicains en
place à jouer ils ont une place à tenir
en tout cas dans l'échiquier politique
sur les valeurs qui sont leur valeur sur
le plan économique peut-être nous
rapprochons quelques fonds des positions
qui sont défendues par la république en
match mais sur d'autres sujets qui sont
par exemple l'éducation des autorités de
ce jeudi
mais qui sont aussi la transition
environnementale au sujet d'énergie nous
avons des positions et nicolas quelle
est la situation du parti dans le
département mais en fait ces élections
législatives vont marquer une nouvelle
défaite dans le département dans un
scrutin national pour les républicains
je précise bien national aucun candidat
n'a réussi à se qualifier au second tour
on en a parlé la semaine dernière à la
suite du premier tour et pourtant ces
dernières années les alertes ont
remporté toutes les élections
intermédiaires dans les yvelines je
parle notamment des municipales des
départementales ou encore des régionales
reste donc un ancrage territorial dans
le département écouter dans le
département des yvelines il reste un
ancrage territorial qui est un ancrage
territorial encore extrêmement forts en
particulier bien sûr le département et
les instances départementales président
du département un certain nombre de
conseillers départementaux qui sont pour
certains projets république en marche
mais en très grande majorité
historiquement plutôt des gens divers
droite des républicains il dit et puis
il reste un certain nombre de maires qui
ne s'affiche pas forcément qu'ils sont
jamais affiché directement et que
va-t-il se passer dans les prochains
jours bien goûté ça se passe dès demain
soir au siège du parti des républicains
un bureau politique doit se tenir
l'objectif c'est d'officialiser cette
position que je vous disais
l'indépendance on ne rentrent pas dans
la coalition avec ensemble le parti de
la majorité présidentielle et donc à
voir ce qui se passe ensuite merci
beaucoup nicolas landry pour ces
précisions je le rappelle la journaliste
pour tv 78 elle rappelle mathias vigneau
puisque vous êtes toujours avec nous un
mot peut-être sur les républicains et
leur avenir donc dans le département
alors dans le département effectivement
je vais reprendre les propos qu'a tenus
il ya une différence notable entre
la perception du parti quel qu'il soit
au niveau national et la perception au
niveau local il est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
au niveau national les républicains ne
font pas forcément recettes c'est à dire
qu' il manque un leadership il manque
quelqu'un qui au niveau national
mène le parti
sur un projet sur une vision de la
société sur de véritables propositions
iront joie et de délitement et
effectivement le résultat des leurs est
à l'initiative même s'il n'est pas
catastrophique n'est quand même pas
flamboyante par contre au niveau local
ce soit dans les tribunes ou ailleurs
mais il ya une autre perception c'est à
dire que les les personnes politiques
qui appartiennent au parti des
républicains on tune comment dire une
une perception positive oui une
perception positive c'est à dire que ils
travaillent ils sont élus locaux
département à la commune à la région et
finalement l'action leurs actions
quotidiennes concrètes sont vus sont
perçus sont ressenties par les par les
citoyens et donc au final il ya une
déconnexion entre le projet politique
nationale d'une part qui ne fait pas
forcément l'objet d'une forte adhésion
mais au niveau local il y à la
reconnaissance d'un travail qui est qui
et des culs qui pensaient comme étant
positif et donc c'est ça qui est
important c'est que il y a deux de
vision il ya la politique des
républicains au local et finalement
gérer de manière que ce soit dans les
yvelines ou ailleurs et on l'a vu les
municipales les régionales les
républicains gagnent les élections c'est
à dire qu'il ya cette reconnaissance du
travail concret quotidien de proximité
mais par contre au niveau national cette
autre chose donc je pense que dans les
yvelines
pour l'instant en tout cas la place des
républicains va rester va rester telle
qu'elle est parce qu'il démontre au jour
le jour leur travail en tout cas c'est
la perception que j'ai je me trouve
peut-être mais voilà c'est vraiment
cette déconnexion entre le national et
le local est pour l'instant donc au
niveau local les républicains restent
fortement ancrés
merci beaucoup rappellent mata duvignau
pour ces précisions et plus pour votre
analyse tout au long de l'émission je
rappelle à vous être maître de
conférences en droit public à lui vécu
merci beaucoup
et on en parlait tout à l'heure
justement avec raphaël mata duvignau en
début d'émission des élections encore
une fois marqué par l'abstention à
quelle a été la participation des
yvelinois pour ce second tour c'est une
charge vous êtes avec nous bon soir bon
sens du style alors justement vous êtes
avec nous pour nous donner ses
explications et galeries et oui un
premier chiffre important c'est 47,34 %
c'est le taux d'abstention au second
tour des législatives dans les yvelines
c'est un tout petit peu moins qu'au
premier tour l'abstention était de 48
des reculs 13% et c'est également moins
qu'en 2017 ou l'abstention avait été de
54,68 % au second tour alors à l'échelle
nationale les yvelines sont quand même
des bons élèves puisque ce chiffre de
47,30 4% est moins élevé que celui de la
france qui est de 53,77 % mais cela
reste quand même un chiffre élevé pour
une élection on parle quand même de
l'abstention comme du premier parti
français on a recueilli reçoit la
réaction de quelques candidats face à
cette abstention écouter elle montre
vraiment une certaine
incompréhension en fait aujourd'hui
d'une élection et des représentants en
fait c'est surtout ça je pense que
vraiment l'abstention elle se joue
énormément là dessus et pas forcément
sur les programmes c'est un échec pour
tout le monde quel que soit celles et
ceux qui sont élus quand tu es aussi peu
citoyennes et citoyens qui participent
au choix ça participe ça + 100 élus
front national à au malaise voire
l'effondrement de notre démocratie elle
traduit aussi un rejet politique le
rejet du bilan d' emmanuel macron le
rejet aussi des institutions puisque là
on rentre dans une période de crise
quand même assez grave au plan national
je pense de crise politique de crise
institutionnelle alors c'est une
habitude aux législatives les gens
s'abstiennent toujours plus qu'aux
élections présidentielles plusieurs
explications dont a parlé tout à l'heure
avec raphaël mata duvignau alors une
offre politique ne correspond plus
vraiment aux préoccupations des citoyens
l'impression de ne pas être représenté
ou de ne pas avoir d'impact par rapport
aux présidentielles en certain
ras-le-bol ou un découragement des
électeurs et c'est une abstention qui se
retrouve notamment beaucoup chez les
jeunes et qui varie selon les
circonscriptions alors parmi justement
les circonscriptions qui ont le moins
joué le jeu pas de surprise ce sont
exactement les mêmes qu'au premier tour
la huitième notamment avec 59 points 52
% d'abstention
on retrouve des records d'abstention
dans ces communes comme l'hymne est par
exemple avec 62 65 % d'abstentions ou
encore montre la jolie avec 62 38% on
retrouve aussi la 9e pareil qu'au
premier tour avec 55 89 % d'abstention
avec notamment aubergenville à plus de
61% bannières sur scène à +2 63% est la
grande gagnante encore une fois les
mureaux avec une abstention record de
plus de 73% trois autres
circonscriptions dépasse la barre des
50% d'abstention dans les yvelines la
sixième la 7e et la 11e alors au
contraire la première circonscription
est au même niveau que le département
avec 47 34 % d'abstention par exemple on
retrouve aussi donc montigny qui était à
44% petit peu plus de 44 % d'abstention
et la 2e circonscription qui joue les
têtes de classe avec seulement 45 %
d'abstention avec par exemple viroflay
39% ou même milon la chapelle avec
seulement 32% et mention spéciale pour
le plus faible taux d'abstention des
yvelines qui est de 28 80 % pour la
petite ville de gan b day qui comptaient
63 inscrits sur les listes
bravo du coup je vous fais oui on peut
le faire arrêter merci beaucoup c'est
l'une charles d'avoir été avec nous le
rappellent nos journalistes pour tv 78
et c'est la fin de notre émission
spéciale consacrée aux législatives 2022
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi et à
très vite sur tv 78
[Musique]